der historiker und architekt robert yoga
der ostwall und seine soldaten stehen
vergessener schiffsfriedhof der ein
die kassen zu füllen werden die
jahr
sturm hat den ufa damm schwer beschädigt
bleibt sind verfallene ruinen die vom
er hat eine entscheidende schwachstelle
diese verwitterten bauten am rande der
ist die letzte veranstaltung dieser art
wie sich zeigt ist der seven stärker als
testgelände von sandy huck wird zum
herren und ein parallel verlaufender
sind viele der bauten vergessen und
hitler eine neue verwendung für sie
knapp zehn jahre später ist von der
des flussufers bieten sich ausrangierte
kriegs tauglichen männer an der front
zufolge soll im most weil ein geheimer
deutschland schmiedet einen plan um die
beginnt anfang des zwanzigsten
überspannen einen künstlichen wasserweg
geheimnisse zu lüften
der geschichte des essens und stößt
ausstellungsräume wurden zur
fließen kanal und fluss friedlich seite
park schliesst seine tore und die
hoffmann kennt die typischen gewässer so
der kanal ist ein wichtiges
von 1907 bringt tausende von 1 und
verleihen die paten heicks dem ufer
verläuft ein gigantisches tunnel
holzkähne werden nach paten geschleppt
1874 halt abermals kanonendonner übers
halbinsel steht ein alter leuchtturm
unterirdische komplex der von einem
verfallenen plattform
versorgungsnetz des königreichs an doch
untersuchungen aus er befasst sich mit
jahrhundert sind geprägt von vielen
brücke liegt im westen polens rund 60
aufschwung gerade einmal sechs meter
jahre feiert das militär hunderttausende
eine metropole ein schmelztiegel
seltsame objekte die aus dem schlamm
den ersten blick wirkt die landschaft
an der ostküste der usa
prägnantesten exponate aus den
sich die usa dramatisch verändert im
gemeinsamen waffengang von
kollegen die geschichte der kolonialzeit
invasion aus dem osten nichts
in frankreich denn die kolonial
vor der ultimativen
über knapp 64 kilometer zum teil
verteidigungssystem dass die us-armee
sind bleibt für die verteidigung des ost
englisches dorf vor dem untergang
die geschütze bereits wieder veraltet
schaulust vergangener tage nichts mehr
großer schießplatz oder eine
operationssälen für ausländische und
ich die örtlichen archive durchforstet
stadt scheinen merkwürdig deplatziert
jahren beginnt das letzte kapitel der
seven schützen sie werden per text
modell für weitere anlagen im ganzen
südwesten englands hat das wasser des
jahrhunderts mit der eröffnung eines
findet
nazi schatz versteckt sein doch das
hug eine halbinsel übersät mit den
vergangener zeit
der improvisierte schutzwall
erforscht diese historisch bedeutsame
verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
eher unauffällig aber
beton boote geradezu an in den 1960 er
herrchen küstenwind verwittert sind sie
bestimmungen des versailler vertrages zu
aber aus beton zu sein liest man boote
neben einem eindrucksvollen ausblick
neuen entdeckungen und die weltmächte
stabilität seit 60 jahren schützen sie
defensive die sowjets nähern sich berlin
entlegenen landschaft west polens ist
gut wie kaum ein anderer
netzwerk zum teil sind dort sogar
verteidigungssysteme auf sandy huck hat
gebäude stammen aus einer zeit als
doch dieses mal geht es nicht gegen die
ausstellungen zu leben gerufen in
tatsächlich auf erste hinweise
ausgaben für militär und befestigungen
bewährungsprobe
infrastrukturprojekt
typischen eingeborenen gewändern
an seite doch 1909 kommt es zur
gebäude werden sich selbst überlassen
hervorragend doch sie können sich keinen
breit
kolonialisierten und ihren herrn öffnet
den kanal vor dem mächtigen stepper sie
entferntesten ecken des kolonialreichs
sollte der feind sich auf den weg machen
verschiedener kulturen aus der ganzen
unverfrorenen vertragsbruch zeugt
schüsse auf dem testgelände ab einige
doch das wettrüsten geht weiter im jahr
entgegensetzen können die größte
bewahrt
navigationshilfe für handelsschiffe
hier errichtet hatten die nike
aufzuarbeiten
doch zwischen ihm und dem reißenden
southern über das ufer in den kanal
kilometer von der deutschen grenze
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
einheimische soldaten umfunktioniert für
aus wie ein flohmarkt zu
anlage dies ist das letzte
aber da war kaum etwas zu finden das
test gartens
walz nur ein kümmerliches her
englands
zu spüren
land
handy druck abgefeuert von visa
dann fallen einem leser verstreuten
ausstellungen kommen aus der mode der
oberirdisch zum teil unter der erde
schienen verlegt
genannt die schiffsrümpfe von paten doch
englands des dorfs perten liegt eine
posieren oder dem was man dafür hielt
umgehen der versailler vertrag hat zwar
nachdem hitler den baustopp verhängt
städte seit vielen jahren
einzig wertvolle in diesen dunklen
überresten des krieges andy hug sieht
schließen
paris die stadt des lichts paris ist
entfernt sie ist teil eines geheimen
ausdrücklich begrenzt aber da stand
das problem mit holz es verortet
amerika nur eine kolonie unter vielen
welt
militärtechnologie
bietet er auf hinweise auf die ursprünge
zeugen von der bewegten geschichte sind
aus beton sind dass staaten die
briten die usa installieren auf sendung
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
reim darauf machen
gespült
werden die routen dicht gemacht
wir sprechen hier nicht von einem
hiervon dreistigkeit zu sprechen wäre
dies war das erste boot das auf grund
zusammengestellt
in paris die größte koloniale
sind ein toller beweis für den
die bauwerke in diesem park stammen
andy hug ist so flach dass es selbst an
flugabwehr radaranlage sollte russische
muslimische kolonialtruppen wurde sogar
werden acht von ihnen zu den
seien die hook ist von entscheidender
der größten und ehrgeizigsten waffen
fluss gibt es nur einen schmalen
schwachstelle ist die region zwischen
hatte mich schon sehr erstaunt dass es
fluren sind die rund 35.000 geschützten
vorherrschaft
katastrophe ein gewaltiger sturm im
auch wenn das nicht so aussieht aber
die feindlichen truppen kamen von dort
bunker ins auge
menschlichen erfindergeist in der
teile des gartens sind heute noch immer
kleidung mit vermeintlich virtuell im
freiheit gleichheit und brüderlichkeit
die hooks und der geburt einer nation
die menschen die hier gearbeitet haben
hatte lag der ostwall erst einmal brach
ist ein großer fluss und direkt daneben
kolonial gebieten inspiriert sind
nicht über wasserwege
99 beschloss die französische regierung
welt zusammen gewürfelt und das macht
einzelnen gestrandeten ruderboot diese
schatten ihrer selbst zeit ihre
aufstellung aller zeiten
geister flotte am ufer eines breiten
partnershops gebracht 60 jahre später
die sturmflut hat das ufer mit voller
befestigungs programms dessen ursprünge
hitler war nicht gerade ein gewiefter
dieser anlage
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
erdwalls an manchen stellen ist dieser
ein großer teil der anlage etwa die
für große restaurierungsprojekte war in
darüber keine informationen
mein vater war seemann und hat er die
normale soldaten gab es dort nicht nur
gesetzt wurde 20 minuten vor der hoch
den flüssen oder und warthe das land ist
offenbar von weit entfernten kulturen
eine moschee erbaut die erste ihrer art
in der arbeit der französischen forscher
noch untertrieben
das erste militärische testgelände in
abenteurer reisten in alle teile des
während des ersten weltkriegs wurde der
bedeutung für die verteidigung der
die usa beschlossen jeden wichtigen
1974 wird das programm eingestampft und
bomber abschießen falls der kalte krieg
projekte der usa werden hier getestet
diese gegend ist sehr gefährlich
seltsamen objekte liegen halb versunken
einem wolkenlosen tag zwischen den
diese brücke ist bis heute
wenn man weiterhin ein geht sieht man
hintergrund diese menschen wurden als
andere wiederum zeugen von amerikas
auf das flussufer trifft kommt es zur
im fall eines einmarschs hätte man die
drüben zuerst mussten sie die
dinger sind überall ein riesiger teils
1000 aufseher haben auch gerecht dass
diesen ort so geheimnisvoll ein
verfallen aber
doch als die alliierten anfingen
sind zwar schon lange weg aber sie haben
für die ausstellung von 1931 wurden in
die holzplanken vermoderten und der
fledermäuse die hier heute leben heute
neuartiges flugabwehrsystem installiert
diese besondere vision der menschlichen
ein kanal welchen sinn ergibt
stellen sie sich ein disneyland der
flusses sie sehen aus wie boote scheinen
einige sehen aus wie typische anlagen
kriegstaktik
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
einen garten mit einem gewächshaus für
der leuchtturm weist auf die
ist der damm dank der boote auf die
sieht man einen dann noch eine und wenn
tunnel oder die eisenbahnschienen liegt
doch noch heiß werden würde
bis zum ersten weltkrieg zurück reichen
in paris
wucht getroffen reißenden strömungen
also hat die regierung ingenieure
wellen kaum zu erkennen ist und nachts
diesen kleinen teil england einfach kein
schlecht ausgebildete mitglieder der
steckte großes potenzial
sache aus seiner brille betrachtet er
schüsse auf ford hancock ab
patentgeschützt die entsprechenden
garten in ein lazarett umgewandelt man
französischen kolonialreichs und
ostküste
den usa
panzersperre auf der straße überwinden
die strömungen im verein ist unglaublich
flut wurde es mit voller wucht ins ufer
etwas exotisches präsentiert ihre
hafen mit küsten batterien zu schützen
erosion und zwar tag für tag
flach es gibt kaum natürliche barrieren
die us-armee verlässt die halbinsel was
all diese artefakte spiegeln den
im cern dem längsten fluss
diese dinger stechen ins auge wenn
er weigerte sich den rückzug anzuordnen
aufstieg zu einer überlegenen
strategische ziele zu bombardieren wurde
sich alle an die regeln halten wenn
hinweise hinterlassen was hier passiert
exotische pflanzen zu eröffnen
jahrhundertwende vor hier sehen sie den
ein testgelände ist ein ort an dem das
brücken geschlossen und im alltag haben
sonderstellung seien die wuchs in der us
geld da zudem war die zeit knapp
doppelte breite angewachsen der kanal
hitlerjugend und männer die zu alt für
darauf hindeuten dass hier etwas sehr
aus dem kalten krieg andere stammen
unter der erde doch der entscheidende
kanal war kurz darauf wieder gefährt
von erfindungsreichtum
es soll new york vor angriffen aus der
unterlagen lägen in berlin aufgrund der
haben einen etwa 60 meter langen teil
eingestellt hunderte tonnen erde
2005 wurde er wieder für die
sechs monaten 32 millionen tickets
konnte man hier fast gar nichts sehen
getrieben
sofort wieder an die us soldaten das
damals gehörte dieser landstrich noch zu
kleidung ihrer sprache ihr verhalten
glaubte dass es sich hierbei um einen
militärmacht
versprachen den leuten dort viel geld
seit 1895 wurden 18 und 12 zoll
großbritanniens
nicht wäre womöglich ein neuer krieg
und der weg führt direkt nach berlin
türkisch sie fließt hier mit bis zu 13
man den blick schweifen lässt scheint
ist über einen durchgang steht das wort
schweres hoch und runter transportiert
aufstieg amerikas zu einer weltmacht
es scheint als wären sie aus allen
behandelte dort viele menschen aus den
geschichte hin er wurde bereits mitte
jemand sie mit absicht hier abgelegt hat
ins andy hug ging es um zwei dinge
hinweis worum es sich hierbei handelt
die anlage einem neuen zweck zugeführt
man könnte meinen dass das eine art
fußgänger sie genutzt
ist gerettet
ausheben lassen flüsse geleitet und eine
die front waren
orient gleich daneben den afrikanischen
offenbar aus zeiten des bürgerkriegs
unternehmergeist und tatendrang
abgetragen und mit sich gerissen
als die russen schließlich über
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht
der leuchtturm wurde am 11 juni 1764 in
hohen sicherheitsstufe durften nur
doch dann hatte der leitende kanalbauer
die grünschnäbel aus der hitlerjugend
friedhof für ausrangierte boote handelt
der erdwall hält das wasser zurück ohne
so wurden hunderttausende deutsche
verkauft die sogar ein nomadenstamm aus
militär seine neuesten entwicklungen und
diese relikte gehen zurück auf die zeit
der plan war die boots wende anzubohren
kathrin oder hat das dunkle geheimnis
wenn sie mit nach frankreich kämen um
luft beschützen das heißt projekt nike
ausgebrochen und ein geheimnisvoller ort
vor fast 50 jahren macht der junge paul
deutschland
wieder den weg von der instabilen
das endlos so weiterzugehen offenbar ist
knoten
manche der boote sind so tief vergraben
des 18 jahrhunderts errichtet
feuer es sind die vorboten eines neuen
im ganzen reich verarbeitet und
kolonien die auf der seite frankreichs
den bau von flugzeugtriebwerken da alle
die bedingungen waren furchtbar es war
befindet sich an der oberfläche eine
wurde zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
maschinen
teilen des erdballs eingeflogen worden
dann müsste das eigentlich aktenkundig
speziell ausgebildete soldaten sie
innerhalb von fünf jahren entsteht eine
holzboote verrotten und metall boote
denken wir zurück ans ende des ersten
zeitenwende für diese menschen machen
einmal um den leuchtturm der die schiffe
du kannst nur mit dem wasser arbeiten
aber sicher wussten wie es nicht
dschungel
prototypen testen und sie eine
angesichts der vielfalt dieser bauwerke
und die alten kerle hatten keine chance
atomwaffen verfügten war jedem in den
neue natürliche barriere geschaffen
soldaten von der roten armee umzingelt
tonnenweise schmutz und schlamm flossen
dem senegal wurde gezeigt man fragt sich
verschifft aber das erklärt nicht warum
eine radikale idee
als die usa nicht mehr nur ein land
geschütze an festungen wie ford händler
dieses gartens erforscht im gewächshaus
damit wasser eindringen kann
eigentlich sollte es um einen
für die polen und die sowjets wäre es
an die westfront gekämpft hat
den franzosen von ihrer kultur zu
ihn würde der fluss den kanal
es wurde ein riesenerfolg
kolonie des britischen weltreichs hin zu
das eine sehr große anlage
dass nur noch die verrottete bugspitze
dass man sie nachdem sie für frankreich
vietnam tonga china
betrieb genommen seitdem steht er genau
seien paul barnett weitet seine
barnett mit seinen eltern einen ausflug
brücke mit einem seltsamen drehgelenk
bedienen
er wurde gebaut um den new yorker
ist gefährlich ganz im gegensatz zum
weltkriegs deutschland hatte den krieg
diesem bau steckt offensichtlich
geschlossene verteidigungslinie zwischen
globalen krieges
und waffen fragt man sich haben wir es
bewährungsprobe unterziehen kann
dunkel es gab mangel an allen ecken und
rosten doch zum glück hatte die
gegen die rote armee aber das hat sie
sicher in den hafen von new york lotste
und gefangen genommen
unter vielen waren sondern zu den
verschlingen ein jahrhundert lang
geliefert um die us hilfen zu
kulturellen austausch stehen aber der
wieso die leute dazu gebracht hatten es
herausragen
diese bauten hier stehen
stromabwärts
niemals dagegen ich bin beeindruckt mit
das geheimnis des boots friedhofs bleibt
erzählen
drei brücken wie diese dienen dazu
einer mächtigen nation die sich mit
usa klar dass die us städte extrem
in den boden und drum herum sollten sich
der ingenieur der
das perfekte einfallstor gewesen
gekämpft hatten wenn schon nicht als
tausende besucher kam sogar der
ans flussufer
auch nach dem ende der kolonial
die nike batterien waren teil der
an dieser stelle
den flüssen oder und warthe der beginn
wurden zb kakao und kaffee bohnen oder
wahnsinnig viel arbeit aber am ende kam
fast 60 meter der aufschüttung werden
sie sollten den ticketverkäufen
handels verkehr zu optimieren diese
gegen die alliierten verloren wurde
und dann um die verteidigung in
geschichte eine lösung parat
weg komplett einseitig die leute wurden
oder auch eine japanisch anmutende
verteidigen
mit einer normalen militärbasis zu tun
enden niemand kümmerte sich um die
nicht davon abgehalten widerstand zu
der wichtigste schutz vor panzern war
wie die maginot-linie in frankreich nur
der boots friedhof erstreckt sich über
militärischen schwergewicht wurden dass
hafenbetriebsgesellschaft bat die leute
gleichberechtigte so doch zumindest mit
spitzentechnologie gegen die
hunderttausende aus den kolonien wurden
angrenzenden kanal
geradewegs nach berlin in die hauptstadt
dem zweiten weltkrieg waren die
hilflos gegen mögliche russische
wie viel seemanns können die boote die
sie haben alles mögliche getestet
schiffe auf großen flüssen passieren zu
ich habe ja als kind sehr gerne gespielt
ungelöst bis bald zwanzig jahre später
zwischen den sowjets und berlin nur noch
ausstellungen sind die nachwirkungen
dann schlick und schlamm ablagern um das
sieben jahre lang untersuchen
beteiligt werden aber in den seltensten
entwaffnet und von gemäß dem versailler
nach dem ersten weltkrieg schießen die
französische präsident
leisten
menschen hier die front war hunderte
oder ist das etwas völlig anderes
doch wie diese ruinen erahnen lassen ist
der festungs front oder erwachte bogen
us-amerikanischen luftabwehr
kommunistische bedrohung stemmte all das
der angriff der spanischen flotte bleibt
kriegszeiten musste es andy hug dafür
sie wollten die festung verteidigen
brücke die von rambus sträuchern gesund
nichts dabei heraus
mehr respekt behandelt hätten aber weit
ihre ausrangierten boote herr zu bringen
rekrutiert um für ihre kolonialherren in
sie heute noch sind
zweieinhalb kilometer am ufer des
vanilleschoten gezüchtet
weggespült
haben war für jeden der die
angriffe werden
wasser um feindliche panzer abzuhalten
dieser zeit noch lange spürbar
dass wir nicht in frankreich sind die
befestigten bis zum heutigen tage
direkt neben diesen mächtigen fluss
dieses loch in der verteidigungslinie
amerikanischen häfen vor allem zwei
fällen kam das geld auch angst die
französische botaniker die pflanzen aus
flussufer wieder aufzubauen die boote
lassen doch dieser fluss gleicht eher
vertrag teile seiner gebiete und seine
projektile zünder reichweite genauigkeit
preise für holz und metall in die höhe
dieses kleine stückchen des ost walz lag
der kanal dann drohte komplett zu
vorherrschaft im nordatlantik anstrebt
kilometer entfernt doch das sollte sich
ist
sie wurden landesweit in der nähe
sehen die veranstalter hoffen auf das
zurückkehrt und es duftet zuerst hatte
auch ostwall genannt
flusses
um das kanalufer zu verstärken
aus doch am horizont lauern bereits neue
ist hier aufs handy holen im süden
gefehlt ein jahrzehnt nach dem
all das findet sich hier auf diesen
großen bedrohungen ausgesetzt
die flache küste seinerzeit nicht das
den krieg zu ziehen die
der standort der anlage liefert einen
die architektur in diesem garten stammte
wollten die deutschen unbedingt stoppen
insgesamt 32 kilometer tunnel
es gibt sehr viele boote und sie
verläuft ein kanal vor 200 jahren waren
bunker sind teil einer riesigen
haben die deutschen taktische kanäle
bevölkerung
den kolonien doch 1906 geht der garten
einem rinnsal
binnen weniger tage durchbricht die rote
kriegsschiffe reinkommen
die explosionen
der strategisch sehr wichtig für die
meisten sprachen kein wort französisch
herkömmliche boote sind für viele nicht
wichtiger städte platziert um die
brechen es musste etwas passieren der
von einer dreistheit zu sprechen wäre
das war aber kein normales gewächshaus
die tatsache dass das fremdartige und
einzige problem
bald ende 1944 ist die wehrmacht in der
große geld denn schon früher haben sich
sandigen flecken am nördlichen ende der
jedes bauwerk ist für sich genommen sehr
mehr als ein jahrhundert lang
die drehbrücke steht hier weil diese
gefahren fortschrittliche waffensysteme
unterirdischen festung unter der erde
angelegt und eine reihe taktischer
durchziehen den polnischen untergrund
scheinen schon lange da zu sein
sie waren den leuten die sie nach
feindlichen bomben und feindlichen
zerstörung von amerikas großen militär
ersten hinweis welchen zweck sie diente
die geschichte des leuchtturms ist auch
aus französisch guyana in china tunesien
der vertrag war eine demütigung für
niederländer für die engländer und
mehr erschwinglich
solche kanäle die wichtigsten
auf diesem gelände konnten sie die
damit der plan aufgehen brauchte man
armee die anlage und rollt auf berlin zu
noch untertrieben
mitte der 1800 90er jahre bahnt sich ein
pleite
das war eine wissenschaftliche
das exotische auch heute noch konjunktur
ein bauwerk an der oberfläche liefert
brücken darüber gebaut mehrere brücken
menschen zoos als wahre besuchermagnete
konzentrierten sich die usa bei der
schön aber sie sind ziemlich merkwürdig
transportrouten für den güterverkehr in
frankreich gebracht hatten komplett
und industriezentren zu verhindern
u-booten
1000 auf see erwarten darüber dass
aus europa zwingen die usa zum aufrüsten
ganze befestigungsanlage illegal war die
man könnte meinen jemand hätte sie
schließlich für die amerikaner
munition und die geschosse auf herz und
eine geschichte des krieges sie beginnt
deutschland das land musste seine
die spitze dieser langen schmalen
forschungseinrichtung und woher kamen
eine ganze flotte von booten als die
der garten brauchte geld der
haben ist in teilen auch auf die
die schiffsbauer fing an mit beton zu
ausgeliefert die koloniale erstellung
großbritannien die menschen waren auf
zusammen gewürfelt
verteidigung new yorks auf das meer nun
einen ersten hinweis auf den zweck
marokko und madagaskar
deutschland sich an die regeln hält kein
angesichts dieser gefahren verloren die
krieg mit spanien an die usa errichten
erwiesen
nieren prüfen ohne die zivilbevölkerung
und dieser leuchtturm heißt den
kolonien abgeben einige der
absichtlich dort platziert aber das land
geschichte der menschen zurückzuführen
halbinsel zeit genau auf den hafen von
die kuriosen bauten stammen aus einer
dorfbewohner davon hörten alten sie
all diese pflanzen aus den französischen
während der amerikanischen revolution
hier in fort hancock legen sie den
das traurige ist dass die deutschen nach
durchschnitts franzose interessierte
dieser anlage
sie angewiesen das waren wichtige
arbeiten beton boote waren schnell und
zu gefährden im laufe der nächsten 50
richten sie ihre aufmerksamkeit gen
industriezentren wurden besetzt und die
verstoß hätte womöglich zu einem neuen
großen küsten batterien an bedeutung
sofort zum schluss insgesamt 15
als die briten den turm erbittert
seeleuten über lange zeit sicher nach
hat sie sich vollständig einverleibt der
oberhalb der anlage verläuft eine
new york city und das zeugt von der
sich nicht sonderlich für die arbeit
kolonie
versorgung sei dann auch hier im dorf
von kolonial ausstellungen oder menschen
mächtige verteidigungsanlagen auf sein
zeit die viele pariser lieber vergessen
grundstein dafür
es muss sehr laut gewesen sein die musik
city vor einem überraschungsangriff
billig zu bauen aber sie waren verdammt
all der hinterlistigen planung und all
krieg geführt
hier obwohl sie sehr wichtig war also
armee schrumpfte auf 100.000 soldaten
himmel 1956 wird auch sandy ruck ein
new york zu navigieren und wieder
strategischen bedeutung dieses orts denn
bewahren wie er seinerzeit im pearl
person
druck etwa ford hancock
verteidigen
seltsame brücke sie ist der schlüssel
im 19 jahrhundert wächst frankreich zu
würden
europäische rüstungsunternehmen hatten
zusammen
zoos waren nicht nur auf frankreich
schwer zu steuern für die befestigung
den hoffnungen nicht mal bereit waren
herauszukommen park aus soja tom
die tiergeräusche das stimmengewirr
musste man einen weg finden die
die deutsche regierung ordnet den bau
jedes große schiff das den hafen von new
harbor passiert war
zum verständnis dass
man fragt sich was sie bedeuten sollen
während des zweiten weltkriegs
die briten lagen hier mit zwei fregatten
beschränkt
artilleriegeschütze mit rauch schwachen
der schaden ist kann er wird 1827
wahrscheinlich auch es auch sehr
beträchtlicher größe heran
bevölkerung für die kolonien und ihre
ausreichend männer und ressourcen in die
auch wird es deutschland untersagt
es gab es ähnliche beispiele in england
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts hatten die
welche geheimnisse liegen ihr verborgen
york an läuft muss an dieser halbinsel
von tunneln und bunkern am der ostwall
welchen zweck sie hatten und warum sie
beherbergt sein druck eine zeltstadt
pulver entwickelt sie feuerten schnell
intensiv nach gewürzen und kamel kurth
vor anker und hatten auch einen
auf einer dieser plattformen stand das
waren zu begeistern um geld in die
einrichtung zu stecken so wurde aus
vorbeifahren
befestigungsanlagen an den grenzen zu
usa nicht genügend kapazitäten um eine
und in den usa
so nah beieinander stehen die geschichte
eingeweiht er schließt burton an das
unterkünfte für auszubildende und ein
bewaffneten wachposten auf dem turm
und verschwanden wieder
wird zu einer modernen festung ausgebaut
ähnlich wie auch england und deutschland
einer lahmen ente ein rohrkrepierer
raketen verfolgungs radar die raketen
errichten
doch dieser ort hat viele gesichter und
die ausstellung war beeindruckend es
deutschland ist praktisch wehrlos
ausreichend große kriegsflotte
hatte frankreich überall auf der welt
aber
mobilisierungs zentrum in den 50er
london berlin new york überall wurden
wurde die us-version solcher waffen
doch als hitler die anlage 1938
selbst waren etwas mehr als einen
aufzubauen
1776 tauchten plötzlich 200
kolonie
waren viele seltene schätze aus den
kilometer weiter südlich stationiert
entwickelt
viele geschichten zu erzählen diese
stattdessen errichteten sie eine reihe
wäre diese anlage wie geplant beendet
besichtigt ist eher wenig begeistert als
dank staatlicher forschungsprogramme
menschen ausgestellt
kolonien zu besichtigen es gab nichts
amerikanische soldaten mit zwei kanonen
die deutschen fühlten sich sehr
nach dem abschuss wurde die rakete von
es gab kolonien in der karibik
von küsten batterien um ihre wichtigsten
auf der kommandant nahm den turm unter
könnte die us technologie mit der der
worden hätte sie der deutschen armee
was wir nicht gezeigt wurde inklusive
verwundbar nach ende des ersten
diesem rat ladens ziel gelenkt während
häfen zu schützen
angesehene wissenschaftler führten
es gab kolonien in südamerika in asien
wertvolle dienste leisten können aber so
anderen mithalten
weltkriegs waren sie in der ganzen welt
menschen chinesen afrikaner mussten den
feuer und schrieb später in seinem
ein anderes radar zeitgleich das ziel
systematische untersuchungen der nicht
hitler 1938 den ostwall besuchte war er
und in afrika vor allem im norden und
wurde nur ein drittel fertig gestellt
verhasst und im osten lauerten gleich
bericht wir haben ihn eine stunde lang
kompass natur um ihre marken und
verfolgte ein computer fügt die daten
hier standen 4 12 zoll moerser die
zwei feinde polen und dahinter die
definitiv enttäuscht da war jemand der
bombardiert aber wir konnten nichts
ohne panzerabwehrwaffen hatten die
westen das neunzehnte und zwanzigste
unterschiede zu klassifizieren
dies ist die erste und einzige
dann zusammen so dass ein treffer
kreisförmig angeordnet waren die
ausrichten rund 100 jahre später haben
sowjetunion deutschland hätte einer
ihre untersuchungsergebnisse sind nach
seine macht offen zur schau stellen
soldaten keine chance gegen die
garantiert war doch wie alle waffen und
dampfbetriebene verschwinde lafette
wollte mit panzer paraden auf den
heutigen maßstäben extrem rassistisch um
granatwerfer sind nach oben gerichtet
schlagkraft der sowjetischen armee
straßen und bombern und kampfflugzeugen
hier unten wurde sie geladen und
die geschosse gehen also von oben auf
im himmel mit
die feindlichen schiffe nieder das
anschließend durch die decken öffnung
einer unterirdischen festungen mit
nach kriegsende wurden die grenzen neu
nach oben geschoben um auf feindliche
kleinen geschützen zwischen bäumen
gezogen das gebiet des ostwald polen
schiffe zu feiern und da man nach jedem
hervor locken konnte er nichts angst
zugeschlagen dem land vor dem man sich
schuss naturgemäß nach laden musste
eigentlich schützen wollte gerüchten
verschwand sie dann wieder nach unten
1939 wird im schutz der westgrenze
daher der name
verschwindet nach wenigen jahren sind
priorität eingeräumt der ausbau des ost
waltz wird auf eis gelegt im selben jahr
marschiert hitler in polen ein die
tunnel werden sich selbst überlassen bis
[Musik]